welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with a
positive side effect of the pandemic
lockdowns 2020 could see a steep drop in
road deaths as Americans are told to
stay at home CBS News reached out to 26
states with the largest number of
traffic deaths historically at least 20
are seeing a noticeable drop in fatal
crashes during the pandemic that could
end up saving lives and money Kris Van
Cleave explains two Boston area teens
died when this speeding pickup lost
control and crashed late last month but
increasingly fatal accidents like this
are on the decline as the pandemic has
drivers staying home please don't come
out and drive unless you absolutely have
to California Highway Patrol captain
Salvador Suarez says that message is
working traffic is down 35 percent
leading to wide open la freeways fire
personnel ambulances law enforcement
they could utilize our freeway systems
and be able to get from caught a call a
lot faster California is among at least
20 states to see fatal crashes drop
during the pandemic down a stunning 84
percent on Golden State freeways alone
Michigan is down 67 percent Illinois 57
it's not all good though Louisiana
Minnesota and Oklahoma have all seen
traffic deaths rise and police
nationwide have seen the rate of drivers
going 100-plus jumped 30 percent but the
overall drop in crashes prompted auto
insurers like Allstate to give hundreds
of millions in refunds less driving
leads to fewer accidents and we just
thought it was the fair thing to do
amid the pandemic New York City saw a
remarkable 46 days stretch without a
pedestrian death the first time that's
happened since the city started keeping
track in 1983 what's the new normal
Meredith Thomason's mother carol was hit
and killed in 2018 while crossing a
downtown Washington DC Street 18 months
she's gone a lot has changed and the
pang and the hole that is in my heart
and in my stomach for her has not
changed Thomason hopes his cities reopen
and drivers return to the roads they'll
slow down and pay attention are we just
gonna go back to the way things were
aye aye sir Tinley hope not but for now
the new normal on the open road is fewer
cars and fewer deaths for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington certainly hope that people
are learning from that